before I get to duck chess I'm going to
try setup chess and here we can see the
explanation before the game players set
up their pieces and pawns one by one
each player has 39 points of material to
spend
pieces can be placed on the first three
rings
pawns on the second and third sounds
simple enough O'Neill is challenging
he's a set of Chess okay
Neil will play a game
you're the only set up chess Challenger
wow so it's an empty board
can I move
let me switch the scene here
so oh my time's ticking okay let's place
a pawn
on uh in the center probably right
I assume pawns can move two squares from
the start
I have 39 points of material
how is this gonna work
oh I guess it shows my number here so
Neil already placed a queen
I don't know if I want a queen though I
feel like three minor pieces should just
be more effective than a queen
I'm just going to keep placing pawns I
feel like I can't go too wrong with that
uh but where do I put my pawns let's
let's make a center Pawn Cube
oh it's too much fun center upon Cube
um I feel like I'm moving just way too
slowly
okay
I can place my king at some point too
oh Neil's kind of copying me
let's play some night somewhere
oh Pawn on B3 maybe I'll Define some
structure like
pawns on
no I don't want pawns on The Rook files
though
because I want to keep the files half
open
oh okay I have an idea
I have a really funny idea does white
move first who moves first
I don't know who moves first
what happens when he runs out of pieces
I have so many questions
I'm gonna put a rook here and attack on
but I don't want to be too obvious let's
put the Knight here first
ah
25 okay so 22 so I have to think ahead
oh let's not put a rook here because
Pawn's too solid
um should I give myself let's just give
myself more nights
wait I need to make room for my king too
oh he's gonna put this King here it's
gonna be so solid
Neil says I have so many Pawn cubes
that's kind of true how many pongus is
this one two
three four
one large pond rectangle I wanted to put
a bishop here but
uh never mind with that plan
I think I might as well place my king
a king had to be placed eventually
this is gonna be insane I'm gonna have
so many nights
I still have more nights to place
and more Pawns of place too
am I going to fill up all my squares
let's just be extra solid
this Knight might have a hard time
developing
oh dear wait Neil's almost out of
material wait what's gonna happen
I have 11 points left I should Place
more Knights
uh
I might as well put a pawn
maybe I could have put a knight there
oh I have an idea
open file
let's put a rook
my one Rook
I'm attacking the undefended Knight
oh I it's my turn again
it's my turn again okay let's put
another Knight
and upon
wait a minute
I only have Pawns
no I have to block my Rook
the only other Square for the pawn is
here and then
oh I miss I misplayed this
could have taken the free nights
okay
oh no am I gonna get smothermated
this is such a bad idea for me
oh no
wait don't hurt me
I'm so close to just losing instantly
here but I think I'm okay
as long as he choose covered
and if Rook takes I take here I could
have just been losing instantly
that would have been such a tragic start
to this variant
I'm down a queen
how much material do I have for the
queen that's a great move by the way
I have this move though
oh dear now I have this move
I mean we might see takes takes check
King D1 Knight takes takes
my king should be on H1 why is it on E1
I really misplayed this
but it's all part of The Learning
Experience
at least I have a lot of nights
okay let's Advance Pawns
actually
maybe I should play King D1
ensuring there's no funny business on C2
it's actually kind of cool we have the
same Pawn information
[Music]
okay now Knight
it's gonna take a while for the knights
to
like become active like Knights usually
enjoy closed positions
but so many pawns is like overly closed
undoubling these Pawns
let's get rid of the blacks last night
okay so material wise I have
three nights
three Knights and two pawns for a queen
does that add up
I think that adds up
so I'm basically up material
on screen space
oh this is such funny Pawn structure
I got confused by the funny Pawn
structure
oh this Queen's gonna be so annoying too
[Music]
I feel it's like hordech has gone wrong
let's take that
okay at least I have this now okay
tactics are beginning to flow
I just trapped the queen I just trapped
the queen
oh no blocks Queen
okay
that could have been bad like if if Bach
had taken with pawn and play Queen F2
sooner I could have just lost all these
Pawns
but now life is pretty good
I want to trap the bishop
it's so close to baggering meat actually
it's Unstoppable mate
rookie Checkmate good game
no mercy
wow